foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hang on
is it fear or courage that compels
oh
give me the old spot can't you may live
to be my best
I'm never giving you a saucepan
[Music]
good
Ness
hold on to the cube
[Applause]
disgusting
Shan
you risked your life to protect the cube
No sacrifice
no Victory if I cannot defeat Megatron
you must push the cube into my chest I
will sacrifice myself to destroy it
Hi Sam
Decepticons
[Music]
beautiful
there is another source of energy hidden
on this planet
[Music]
thank you
you'll never stop at one
I'll take you all along
please
Sam where are you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
fulfill your destiny
scope Electrify 10 factors
Let's Roll
this planet will be dark forever
[Applause]
don't like your brother
they were your brothers
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
sure screams
you picked the wrong planet
you fall
thank you
[Music]
stay behind me
get the heavy weapons
[Music]
right
what the hell was that thing
that
is Shockwave
[Music]
why was he after this
it's impossible this is an engine part
from a long lost Autobot ship
as you're working with you
disabled things looking at me what
[Music]
people got an ugly to stop the car with
it
there's a block crap
hey how do we get out of here hey come
on no no no oh Lord Jones let me just
get on this slide
wow
we gotta move I need to Decepticons
always get the good move we bout to be
eating people
[Music]
what's up
thank you
[Music]
what's up
I'm coming for you
[Music]
I'll kill you
George
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
no
Impossible by ruining everything
[Music]
get off me
get up out I can't go on but you gotta
keep fighting Tank's empty bro
there's more of them coming if you'll
get up and fight we're gonna die let's
go
attacks
Optimus is here
thank you
[Music]
foreign
gonna die
come on come on
[Applause]
you know
about my ass
[Music]
come on
you see my face your life is done come
on come on come on come on
yeah
honor to the end
you're so happy we met
[Music]
all right
quickly I'm setting off lockdown's
grenade hold tight
[Music]
for I am Reborn
which reminds me Agnes called wondered
if you're available for a bit of a
snuggle this evening I'll never snuggle
with Agnes do I look available
get out of my way move
foreign
Royal Navy Museum I knew it
B I'm gonna develop the cops
[Music]
we need Decepticon
this is where it gets intense more
intense
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
got there they're all around us and I
just have so much road rage actualized
rage that's it
oh you want some
goodbye
[Applause]
I'm not driving he's driving
[Music]
whoa
notice how you get to the big league
what the hell you're out of your mind
surprise
lightning four has visual on Optimus
Prime
[Music]
thank you
um
I am bumblebee your oldest friend
Optimus
I would lay down my life for you
[Music]
bumblebee your voice
I have not heard it since Cybertron fell
what have I done
Christmas
where's b127
Lake hit a little traffic
uh Optimus
[Music]
destroy the Launchpad let none Escape
Cybertron has fallen get to the Escape
parks there are other Autobots scattered
across the Galaxy we must reach them if
we hope to survive
this is our hook we have to fight for it
we will fight on but we must find Refuge
first I found a planet that's well
hidden Earth you will travel there and
establish a base for us once we've
gathered the others we'll join you
you must protect the planet if the
Decepticons find it then our people are
truly finished now go home
beautiful
good luck Soldier I'll buy you some time
[Music]
there the one of the Tower
thank you
you think these little chains can hold